I've never made a mistake in my career.
Uh,
Geez,
I,
I really do tend,
I have made lots and lots of mistakes,
but I tend to erase them,
uh,
as,
as from my,
from my,
uh,
a mind,
you know,
I mean,
every day I make a mistake as I try to
write a piece of fiction or is I try to
write a story.
Uh,
and,
and on a larger sense,
I make mistakes thinking that,
uh,
oh,
I've done this kind of thing.
Therefore of course I can do this
roughly similar adjacent thing.
I mean,
it's the mistakes of Hubris I suppose.
Uh,
but I,
you know,
it's to me,
to my mind,
it's better to make those mistakes and
saying,
man,
now maybe I can't,
you know,
a tap dance,
even though I,
you know,
can tell jokes,
uh,
it's better to make those mistakes in
the attempt to,
to live the amateur spirit,
if you will,
a then to a stick in one little silo
where one has proven oneself.
I mean,
the,
I,
I think the errors of hacked them are,
are more dangerous than the errors of
overreach.
And I've over,
I've overreached I will grant.